well I I did have like a panic attack
this last summer I was writing for a
show which Oh Sara show Sara so
alcoholic who the show and this is that
when you were still the singer no now oh
yeah we did it like and was that is that
weird though like you dated her and now
you're writing you know it wasn't and
which made me think oh she must been the
boss and the relations ition yeah but
yeah I just was having like waking up
with panic attacks and just I just saw
my whole life as this writer and I was
like I don't I want to like perform yeah
I quit that job which I really need
money but I I had to I had to like try
to do something right so when you would
know what is that decision like like no
I mean I okay this is the let me just
get gets hard but yeah all right so this
is making me money yeah I'm gonna how I
assure ins
white health insurance I'm also around
other people that are creative so it
must feel good I would think that it
would feel good to be in a room with
other people that because I know what
writing steps are like when I even at
mad TV yeah you know we had Mike
Hitchcock writing he was on all the
Christopher Guest movies yeah yeah he's
a Groundlings guy he's really talented
yeah he laid a producer Glee but we have
you know even guys a blank a patch wrote
for a year yeah and people like that so
you're around other comedians or people
that I've you know yeah so when you make
that decision how does that is that
spontaneous or does no it was building
you know I wrote for inside Amy Schumer
for four years
oh my and it's just like it's a little
bit of a trap even though they're great
jobs it's not exactly what you know we
want to do I mean I didn't you were just
a you know like a staff writer you can't
write BNE I'm not gonna write I mean
that's not my strength I don't think
it's mine either
really yeah mm-hmm I think that isn't
one of those right I think that is one
of your fine well well I I just was like
I I want to perform I think that's was
like an over why I
saw the energy and the time and plus
like I felt like the time's running out
like I'm getting older and it was just
like I felt like I was in that coma
and I didn't kind of woke up and was
like no this you're on this path I even
realize that I have that moments of like
panic like you know that scroll you do
online to put in your birthday and
you're like seeing that yeah like throws
[Music]